it's like we're live so the first
question comes from aaa star trader
ross you've linked cattle mutilations to
uaps and he's wondering if you have
heard of human mutilations
potentially with special force
assistance
look there's a lot of claims uh i mean i
think the most substantive evidence that
i've seen today that substantiates that
there is indeed a danger for humans
posed by uaps is the kolaras brazil
incident
which my friend james fox the filmmaker
is currently investigating in brazil
but
yes i do think there's a link between
cattle mutilations and the phenomenon
whatever it is i don't know
i have been absolutely
swamped
with veterinarians
um
animal carers up and down the east coast
particularly in australia since i aired
the story of mick and judy cook who live
up near gimpy in far north queensland in
australia
and they've suffered i think they know
of the loss of 15 cattle but as far as i
know there's been no human
uh
woundings or killings or whatever
in this part of the world no i shake my
head as i say that because it just
sounds preposterous you know we're
talking about animals being mutilated
for some reason
and
i wish i could understand the phenomenon
i don't know what it is
but
i've seen up close
the kind of injuries that these animals
suffer
and
they're not
injuries that can be caused by
a simple scalpel or even a
laser cutter or
all manner of things that you think
would be able to do that kind of
operation you're talking about
completely exsanguinated bloodless
animals that sometimes within a few
minutes are found with key organs
missing from their bodies with no
apparent disruption to the other organs
and the one that really shocked me was a
a very well respected veterinarian in
far northern new south wales about 10
hours north drive of where i live
and he told me that he was
doing an autopsy on a cow that was found
dead in a paddock
in a field and um he in order to do
in a paddock in a field
the british term paddock yeah australia
but uh and he moved the two stomachs
to get to the third stomach
and then he discovered that the third
stomach wasn't there
and he sent me the autopsy records and
the photographs to show what
what he saw and
as he said to me he said ross i can't
think of any way
he says if anybody's ever done an
autopsy on a car that's how you do it
that's how you get to the third stomach
you have to lift aside the other two
stomachs and he said
i've never seen anything quite like it
because when he got to that third cavity
it just it was empty something had
removed the stomach
and
there's an incredible mystery there and
i wrestled with it to be honest i
wrestled as a journalist with whether i
should link cattle mutilations to the
phenomenon but um
so many people have contacted me since i
feel very much vindicated in terms of
making that decision i just can't
explain it but in terms of human
mutilation the ones that i do know of
are the brazil calaras case i've spoken
very haltingly with a spanish friend uh
too
um
what was it spanish or portuguese she
speaks both but uh
she spoke to uh some military people
that uh uh
gave me a bit of a background on collars
and uh i'm really thrilled to hear that
james fox is now in
uh
the town where a lot of this happened in
brazil and i'm really excited to see
what he comes out with with his film